kim and kanye are expanding the west
household i love this good news i love
spreading good news nancy because in the
new year is going to bring kim and kanye
a new bundle of joy
having another baby would mean
everything to me
a source close to kim telling e.t that
the couple is expecting baby number
three via surrogacy do you think mommy
and daddy should have one more baby no
yeah no one or yes yeah and what's the
answer i don't know nowhere yes yeah
the baby is reportedly due in january
our source telling us quote they took
their time finding the right woman to
carry their baby and of course they are
being very hands-on during this process
kim had health complications with both
daughter north now 4 and sun saint now
21 months besides fertility issues she
has a serious medical condition placenta
accreta which makes another pregnancy
life threatening doctor is like he's
like for sure now you should not carry
another baby
the couple worth an estimated 335
million is paying their surrogate 45
thousand dollars in 10 monthly
installments
if you use a stargate
nobody has to know the whole time that
is a benefit
the 36-year-old considered a family
member to carry her third baby you carry
the baby
give it to me
[Music]
what
but ultimately hired an agency to find a
suitable surrogate who is prohibited
from smoking and drinking and using hot
tubs or hair dye our source telling us
quote kim and kanye wouldn't make any
wild demands they just want a healthy
pregnancy
you